اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
مجددا الى تغطيه العربيه المتواصله
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين فيما تتواصل المواجهات
لليوم الثالث على التوالي بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تدور حرب
اخرى لا تقل ضرابه بين الطرفين وهي حرب
البيانات
فبينما اكد الجيش ان جميع مقرات القياده
العامه ما زالت تحت سيطرته رغم الاشتباكات
المتواصله قالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
سيطرت على مقرات داخل القياده العامه
المشهد تكرر في مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
الصوت
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
اليوم محدوده جدا اقل عده بكثير من اليوم
الاول من الامس نحن نعصر عملياتنا في هذه
المرحله في التصدي لمحاولاتهم اقتحام بعض
المواقع مقرات القوات المسلحه في محيط
القياده العامه لجميع مقرات القياده
العامه هي الان
تحت سي
طره كما نفل العميد نبيل عبد الله الناطق
باسم الجيش السوداني للعربي ادعاءات قوات
الدعم السريع بالسيطره على اجزاء من مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه والقصر
الجمهوري وقصر الضيافه
انه لا صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مخرطه في هذا العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القصر
الجمهوري هذه اساليب مظلمه الامر الثاني
نحن نؤكد اننا في القوات المسلحه لاننا
قوات محترفه وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم
تماما بجميع قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه
الحالات نحن نتقيد تماما
بمقررات القانون الدولي الانساني قانون
النزاعات المسلحه في هذا النزاع المسلح
في المقابل رد يوسف عزه المستشار والسياسي
لقائد القوات الدعم السريع على تصريحات
الناطق باسم الجيش مؤكدا للعربيه سيطره
الدعم السريع على القصر الجمهوري ومقرات
القياده العامه
نحن نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر
على كل المغاره
المتواجده على طول كل الوزارات نحن نسيطر
على كافه مداخل ولايه الخرطوم الكباري
كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدن الثلاثه نحن
فقط عبر هذه القناه نطمن المواطنين ان
هنالك دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على
مواطنين او ينهب وممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه
رخيصه نحن نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل
المواطنين في الشارع نوع من المواطنين نعم
من المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها
هذا واعلن الجيش السوداني سيطرته على
معسكر لقوات الدعم السريع في مدينه الفاشر
واظهرت لقطات جنود من الجيش وهم يتجولون
في المعسكر الواقع بولايه شمال دارفور
[موسيقى]
الى ذلك اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان قرارا بحل الدعم
السريع واعلانها قوه متمرده على الدوله
وذلك بحسب بيان وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه
كما اكدت الخارجيه ان كل الوسطات الوطنيه
لدمج الدعم السريع بالجيش قد بات بالفشل
وجاء في البيان ايضا ان الجيش يعتمد
استراتيجيه قتاليه لتقليل الخسائر
وطالب قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو عبر سلسله تغريدات نقلتها وكاله
رايترز عن حسابه في تويتر طالب المجتمع
الدولي بالتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضد ما
اسماها بجرائم رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان
في غضون ذلك افاد مراسل العربيه في محيط
قاعده مروي العسكريه بان القاعده اصبحت
ساحه حرب مع تجدد الاشتباكات هناك
ونقل مراسلنا عن متحدث باسم الجيش
السوداني قوله ان الجيش سيتعامل مع كل
السيناريوهات لاستعاده مطار مروي
من مدينه مروي الضمير مجددا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي الذي يتابع هذه الاوضاع عن
كثب نزار اهلا وسهلا بك مجددا جديد المشهد
الميداني من عندك في هذه الاوقات واين
تتركز الاشتباكات وهل ما زالت الشباكات
مستمره في محيط القاعده
لاكثر من ثلاث ساعات الاشتباكات متوقفه
كانت قبل ثلاثه ساعات من خلفي مباشره في
قاعده مروي الجويه حيث تظهر الصوره هذه
القاعده وهذا المطار كانت هنالك اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله بالمدفعيه
استمعنا الى اصوات كانت مدويه في محيط
وعموم هذا المكان هنا في مدينه ملوي وفي
المناطق المحيطه الان عاد الهدوء مجددا
الى محيط مطار مروي الدولي الذي الحقت به
قاعده عسكريه عملياتيه الدعلي القوات
الجويه السودانيه الان لا نلاحظ اي اثار
لاعمده الدخان خلافا لتلك التي كانت قبل
ثلاث ساعات هذا يفسر ويؤكد وحسب ما نتابع
ونشاهد بان العمليه العسكريه توقفت الان
لا نقول توقفت بشكل كامل لاننا امس الاول
ويوم امس توقفت ثم تم استعادتها توقفت ثم
بدات مره اخرى هذا ايضا يشير الى اننا
ربما خلال ساعات
سنستمع الى ذوي اطلاق النار والى اعمده
الدخان التي نراها تتصاعد فوق السماء هذه
القاعده الجويه هنا في مدينه مروي طيب هل
وصلت وفق معلوماتك ومتابعتك هل وصلت الى
قوات الدعم السريع امدادات ودعم من ولايات
اخرى نزار
حتى الان المعلومات المتاحه لا وجود لاي
دعم وصل ليس هنالك الان معلومات تشير او
تؤكد او تنفيذ ولكننا هنا في مروي لم نلحظ
ولم نشاهد ارتالا عسكريه وصلت عبر
السيارات للدفع الرباعي تتبع للدعم السريع
لم نشاهد هذه المشاهد العسكريه ما نشاهده
فقط هو حاله من الترقب هو حاله من
الاستعداد حاله من التحفز من قبل الجيش
السوداني لاستعاده هذه القاعده هذا ما
اكده المتحدث باسم الجيش وهذا ما تسعى
وتعمل عليه القوات المسلحه السودانيه بحسب
مصدر وقائد عسكري هنا في هذه المدينه
مدينه مروي هذا صعيد عسكري ان كنت تسال او
تستفسر عن الصعيد الميداني او الصعيد
المجتمعي للمواطنين وللمدنيين فهم ايضا
يتابعون عن كثب هم الان في عين المكان هم
في قلب العاصفه عاصفه هذه المعركه التي
دخلت يومها الثالث دون توقف كامل ودون
استمرار كامل يتابعون كل جزئياتها عبر
القنوات عبر العربيه عبر الحدث عبر مختلف
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
عدد من ابناء هذه المدينه مدينه مروي هم
داخل هذه القاعده بحكم عملهم ضمن القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ايضا يحاولون ان
يتعرفوا على وضعيه مادارا من معارض داخل
هذه القاعده الاوضاع الانسانيه مطمئنه او
مطمئنه داخل هذه المدينه الطرقات سالكه
الكهرباء عادت الى الاستقرار خدمات المياه
متوفره السوق الرئيسي للمدينه كان مغلق
ولكنه يبدو انه بدا العوده الى العمل
وخاصه المحاله التجاريه المرافقه للاحياء
الوسطيه هنا في مدينه مروي بنزار ما سر
هذا التناقض لانه وحدات الدعم السريع
غادرت الى الجبال المطله على قاعده والتي
نراها في صدر هذه الصوره يعني عدد او
عشرات العربات الدفع الرباعي للقوات الدعم
السريع غادرت القاعده وان الجيش قاده
قوسين او ادنى او دخل لاستعاده القاعده
ومن ثم يعني نستيقظ اليوم يعني يقال لنا
او المعلومات المتواتره ان لا القاعده ما
زالت تحت سيطره قوات الدعم السريع لم
استمع جيدا الى السؤال بحكم التقطع الصوت
هذا التناقض اذا كنت تسمعني نزار بالامس
يعني كان في كلام كان في الكلام انه قوات
الدعم السريع انسحبت من القاعده باتجاه
الجبال المقابله للقاعده والتي نراها في
صدر الصوره الان وانه في عشرات من سيارات
الدفع الرباعي التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
انسحبت وتركت القاعده للجيش وان الجيش
السوداء القوات الجيش دخلت
اليوم استيقظنا لا على خبر يعني منافي
تماما متعارض تماما مناقض تماما بان
القاعده ما زالت تحت سيطرت قوات الدعم
السريع بالكامل ما سر هذا التناقض دائما
الجيش السوداني بحسب بيانه يوم الامس
وبحسب التصريحات الخاصه للعربيه من مروي
قال ان قوات الدعم السريع اضطرت مجبره
للخروج من القاعده صوب الجبال التي تراها
الان مباشره تلك الجبال في مؤخره الصوره
اضطرت قوات الدعم السريع بحكم اشتداد
العمليه العسكريه داخل مطار مروي الى ان
تتوجه
برفقه عتادها مخلفه ايضا اعتاد عسكري
وسيارات واليات عسكريه لكن السيناريو الذي
حدث صباح اليوم عندما استيقظنا صباحا
استمعنا الى ذوي المدفعيه الثقيله
والاستماع الى طلقات الرصاص والى القاذفات
بعدها مباشره جاءت التاكيدات من قياده
الجيش بان مطار مروي هو الان بحوزه قوات
الدعم السريع لا تفسير حتى الان لماذا
انقلبت هذه الموازين
لكن نحن نعرف وحسب ايضا العسكريين بان
منطقه مروي هي الساحه لمعركه عسكريه
والمعركه العسكريه فيها حسابات التموضع
والتموضع في مكان اخر الانسحاب ومن ثم
معاوده الكره ربما تكون هذه الوضعيه هي
وضعيه حرب وضعيه لخلق موازين وتمدد في
حدود قوى اخرى هذا هو الواقع لكن ليس من
تفسير منطقي وليس من التفسير قاطع لماذا
كانت قوات الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه
يوم الامس مسيطره على القاعده واليوم هي
من تحاول ان تدخل الى هذه القاعده ليس من
تفسير سوى الاستماع الى تحليلات العسكريين
او تصدر بيان او معلومات رسميه من الجيش
يوضح طبيعه الذي تم في الساعات الماضيه
وما الذي جعل وضعيه القاعده بهذه الشكل
طيب نزار في موقع استراتيجي اخر في مدينه
مروي يعني غير الموقع الاستراتيجي للقاعده
الجويه في مروي هو سد مروي صحح لي
المعلومات
هذا السب هل من يسيطر عليه
[موسيقى]
سد مروي هو واحد من الصروح الاستراتيجيه
المهمه هو سد
كهرومائي انشا في العام 2010 هنا في
السودان
سنحاول ان نقرب الصوره لنوضح الاتجاه الذي
يوجد به سد مروي الان هذه هي القاعده لكن
في اتجاه الصوره على ناحيه الشمال اذا ما
امتدت بالنظر مباشره على بعد كيلومترات
قليله باتجاه مسار الصوره يوجد سد مروي سد
مروي الان تسيطر عليه بطبيعه الوضعيه
الامنيه وبطبيعه انه مرفق استراتيجي
القوات المسلحه السودانيه موجوده في هذا
المرفق قوات الشرطه بحسب انها تؤمن قوات
الاحتياط ايضا تؤمن وحدات مختلفه من الجيش
من الشرطه تؤمن كل المرافق الاستراتيجيه
وسد مروي يقع في هذا الاطار اطار انه مرفق
استراتيجي ولم يدخل اطلاقا في مسار هذه
العمليه العسكريه هل من مؤش بان قوات دعم
السريع ربما تتقدم في الساعات المقبله
للسيطره على هذا السد ام لا يعني لا يمكن
لا يمكن التنبؤ باي شيء من هذا القبيل وان
السد ربما سيظل بمن ا عن
التجاذبات والمواجهات العسكريه بين
الطرفين لا حديث الان لا حديث البته عن
تقدم او جعل سد مروي هدفا استراتيجيا
لقوات الدعم السريعه او اي قوه اخرى هو
يظل بعيد عن كل هذه المشاهد العسكريه
انقطع الاتصال ولكن ساواصل عبر المايك ليس
موضوع الان ضمن خارطه الاستهداف هو بعيد
كل البعد عن مواقع العمليه العسكريه حتى
جميع المدن في هذه الولايه سواء كانت
كريمه او مدينه حلفا او مدينه دونكولا
كلها هذه المواقع هي بعيده كل البعد عن
مسار العمليات العسكريه انقطع الاتصال
بالليس بامكاني ان استمع الى السؤال
والصوره واضحه وشكرا جزيلا لك نزار على كل
هذه المتابعه والمعلومات التي توافينا بها
من مدينه مارب وتحديدا من محيط القاعده
الجويه فيماوي نزار بقداوي شكرا جزيلا لك
قبل ذلك نفى مصدرهم في الجيش السوداني
للعربيه ما تم نشره من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع حول اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان واكد
المصدر للعربيه ان الاشتباكات جرت حول
مقري البرهان وحمتي وقد تم ابعاده هذه
القوات وان فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع
لمقر البرهان مضلل وغير حقيقي
هذا واعلن الطرفان المتنازعان في السودان
السيطره على مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في
ام درمان حيث اكد الجيش السوداني استعاده
السيطره على المبنى وبث بيانا وصف فيه
قوات الدعم السريع بالميليشيات
وذكر الجيش السوداني في بيانها ان قوات
الدعم حاولت تدمير البنيه التحتيه
للتلفزيون بعد عجزها عن السيطره عليه
واذاعه بيانها لتعود لاحقا قوات الدعم
السريع وتبث صورا من خارج مقر الاذاعه
والتلفزيون
وتؤكد سيطرتها بالكامل عليه وتنفي وجود اي
اشتباكات مع الجيش حول محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون
هذا واظهرت الصور اندلاع النيران في مدرج
مطار الخرطوم جراء الاشتباكات المستمره
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
كله
كله فاضي
الى ذلك جدد الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلاميه حسين طه دعوته الى الوقف الفوري
لاطلاق النار في السودان مشددا على ضروره
العوده الى المسار السلمي من اجل التجاوز
الازمه الخطيره التي تهدد امنه وسلامه
ووحده السودان كما واكد بيان المنظمه على
دعم الجهود الرامي الى التوصل الى هدنه في
السودان بهدف ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
وتسهيل لاجلاء الجرح والعالقين من المناطق
القريبه للاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه
في هذه الاثناء حث المبعوث الاممي للسودان
فولكر بيرتس جميع الاطراف على ضروره
احترام التزاماتها الدوليه بما في ذلك
ضمان حمايه جميع المدنيين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لم
يلتزم بالامس بوقف القتال الذي اعلن عنه
لاغراض انسانيه الا بشكل جزئي مشيرا الى
خيبه امل شديده جراء تجدد الاشتباكات
وبالطبع هذه الاخبار العاجله التي ترونها
على الشاشه امين عامه الامم المتحده يدعو
الى وقف فوري للقتال في السودان
الان موقف من الامين العام للامم المتحده
يدعو الى وقف فوري
للقتال في السودان بالطبع مبعوث بريطانيا
بالامم المتحده قال ان مجلس الامن الدولي
سيبحث العنف في السودان اليوم
ولكن الموقف الابرز هو موقف امين عام
الامم المتحده الداعي الى وقف فوري للقتال
في السودان
الى القاهره الان معي مجددا الدكتور محمد
فايز فرحات مدير مركز الاهرام للدراسات
دكتور محمد اريد قراءتك لليوم الثالث من
هذه المعارك واي سيناريو سواء عسكري او
سياسي سيتمظهر في الايام المقبله نتيجه
مجريات المعارك تحديدا في الخرطوم
يعني في رايي اليوم الثالث لم يختلف كثيرا
ربما يعني تراجعت حده المواجهات او على
الاقل لم تشهد المواجهات يعني تحولا يمكن
القول على اساسه بان المواجهات انتهت او
العمليات او الاشتباكات يعني على
يعني مقربه من الانتهاء على ما يبدو
العمليه سوف ما زالت مستمره خاصه في ضوء
البيانات المتضاربه وسعي كل طرف التاكيد
على انه يعني
متمسك بموقفه السيناريوهات اعتقد انها
ستحددها
المجريات المواجهات خلال الساعات او خلال
الايام القليله المقبله في تقديري ان قوات
الدعم السريع ستواجه ازمه كبيره خاصه مع
تحقيق الجيش يعني قدر من النجاح في مواجهه
قوات الدعم السريع في هذه الحاله في رايي
سيكون هناك ازمه كبيره داخل قوات الدعم
السريع ل هذه القوات هذه ليست قوات نظاميه
لا تحكمها عقيده قتاليه او عقيده يعني
امنيه
مؤسسيه لكن هذه القوه او هذه القوات الدعم
السريع هي بالاساس مجموعه
تنتظم حول مصالح كبيره تجمع
العلاقه بين قيادتها وبين الكوادر داخل
هذه المجموعه وبالتالي في رايي ان طبيعه
تكوين قوات الدعم السريع هي العلاقه تقوم
على علاقه نفعيه او علاقه مصلحيه ما بين
عناصرها وبين هذا الكيان اذا واجهت ازمه
في مواجهه يعني الجيش النظامي السوداني في
هذه الحاله اعتقد يعني قد تكون هناك ازمه
تماسك داخل قوات الدعم السريع خاصه اذا
يعني دكتور يعني في سؤال يطرح نفسه مع كل
الامكانات التي لدى الجيش السوداني وهو
كما نقول الجيش
النظامي الشرعي الرسمي مع ذلك لم يتمكن من
الحسم يعني المعارك في محيط مقراته سواء
في محيط مقر القوات المسلحه العامه في
الخرطوم في مطار الخرطوم وغيره من المقرات
حتى قاعده مروي الجويه وهي قاعده
استراتيجيه لم يستطع
الجيش استعادتها استعادتها لماذا يعني
الحسم غير متوفر في هذه المرحله
يعني في راي هذا راجع الى طبيعه المواجهات
يعني هذه المواجهات ليست بين جيوش نظاميه
هناك انماط مختلفه في التسليح بين الجيش
النظامي وبين قوات الدعم السريع قوات
الدعم السريع تعتمد على انماط معينه من
التسليح وبالتالي طبيعه المواجهه لا يمكن
من وجهه يعني او بجانب الجيش السوداني
استخدام الاسلحه الثقيله حاولت قوات الدعم
السريع السيطره على قواعد جويه لاستخدام
السلاح الجوي لكن على ما يبدو اجهضت هذه
المحاوله من جانب الجيش السوداني وبالتالي
تظل المواجهات محصوره في انماط معينه من
التسليح طبيعه قوات الدعم السريع كقوه
عسكريه او كميليشيا يعني وفقا لتوصفات
الجيش السوداني هي تعتمد على انماط معينه
من العمل القتالي وانماط معينه من التسليح
هذه الانماط في رايي تضع سقفا او تضع
قيودا على التوسع في استخدام القوه
العسكريه او العسكريه الثقيله من جانب
الجيش السوداني هناك عامل اخر يعني سيساهم
في رايي في حسم هذه المواجهه الواضح حتى
الان ان قوات الدعم السريع لم تستطع يعني
تامين او توظيف حاضنات اجتماعيه او حضانات
سياسيه داخل المجتمع السوداني القوه
السياسيه السودانيه ما زالت اما تقف على
حياد او انها تدعو الى او في انتظار حسم
هذه المعركه للحديث مجددا عن معادله
سياسيه جديده او الحديث عن العمليه
السياسيه مجددا لكن الواضح ان القوه
السياسيه في السودان لم تنحاز الى يعني
طرف بعينه هذا في رايي يعني يساهم بشكل
كبير في عدم تحول هذه المواجهه الى حرب
اهليه وقد يساهم في حسم المواجهه بين
الجانبين لمصلحه الجيش السوداني دكتور
محمد ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معي ساعود
اليك بعد قليل في سياق هذه التغطيه
في ردود الافعال الدوليه قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي خلال لقاء نظيره
البريطاني جيمس قال ان بلاده تشعر بقلق
عميق اتجاه استمرار للشبكات في السودان
مؤكدا على اهميه الاتفاق مع الحلفاء على
ضروره وقف الاشتباكات الدائره بلانك ان
الشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
لتكناتهم وان الشعب يتطلع الى دوله
ديموقراطيه من جهه وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه جيمس كليفري طرفي الصراع الى
اعطاء الاولويه للسلام لانها
الاسماء
ثمه قلق عميق مشترك بشان القتال في
السودان والتهديد الذي يشكله على المدنيين
وعلى السودان وعلى المنطقه نشعر بقلق عميق
تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان نقشنا
هنا في اليابان الوضع في السودان مع حلفاء
في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا وهناك اتفاق
مشترك حول ضروره ان يعمل العسكريون على
ضمان حمايه المدنيين وغير المقاتلين وكذلك
مواطنين من دول اخرى لدينا وجهه نظر
مشتركه حول ضروره وقف القتال بالسودان على
الفور وعوده طرفين نزاع الى المحادثات
فالشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للذكنات ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه
المحادثات التي اجيناها كانت واعده لوضع
السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
في وقت سابق اليوم اجرينا نقاشا حول الوضع
في السودان وقد تواصلنا مع اصدقائنا في
المنطقه العربيه وسنستمر في التواصل وفي
نفس الوقت اود التاكيد اننا نتفق مع ما
قاله الوزير بلينكن في الدعوه لوقف فوري
للعنف والعوده لمفاوضات تسير باتجاه انتاج
حكومه مدنيه وهذا بالتاكيد هدفنا الاكبر
وكلانا سنستمر بالعمل مع الولايات المتحده
واصدقائنا في افريقيا وفي العالم العربي
للوصول الى السلام والى ديمقراطيه مدنيه
القتال بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع ما زال مستمرا وسرعان
ما تداولت الصحف العربيه والغربيه اخبار
المواجهات في السودان لناخذ جوله على ابرز
عناوين الصحف الغربيه
صحيفه ولسوجان الامريكيه عنون صراع مميت
على السلطه بين اكبر جنرالين في السودان
الصحيفه تقول ان الفشل في انهاء القتال
بسرعه ومعاوده المحادثات مع القاده
المدنيين قد يدفع السودان مره اخرى
للانزلاق الى حرب اهليه وفقه محللين اما
صحيفه التلغراف البريطانيه
انفجرت في السودان السودان يتصدع تحت
تاثير المرتزق الروس وقد يتم ربط قوات
الدعم السريع بمجموعه التي قيل انها ساعدت
في تدريبهم وتجهيزهم قد تواجه تشاد
واريتريا وجنوب السودان طوفانا من
اللاجئين ما يزيد من صراعاتهم الداخليه
الى صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه تحت
عنوان السودان يخشى من حرب اهليه بعد
انفجارات تهز العاصمه القتال في دارفور
عنصر قابل للاشتعال والصراع تعد دارفور
موطنا للعديد من الجماعات المتمرده التي
قد تنخرط في القتال صحيفه لوفيغرو
الفرنسيه عنونه التنفس بين العسكريين يجعل
الخرطوم تغرق في الفوضى على الرغم من
الدعوات العديده للهدوء من المجتمع الدولي
والقوى السياسيه السودانيه لا يبدو ان ايا
من الطرفين مستعد للتفاوض مصدر دبلوماسي
غربي في الخرطوم صرح للصحيفه بوجود عده
محاولات اقليميه ودوليه للمصالحه لكن
الامر معقد فالطرفان منخرطان في اسلوب
اللفظي وعسكري واحد
ومع احتدام المعارك تبرز سيناريوهات
الموقف الراهن في السودان اولا ورغم
الضبابيه الصوره فان سيناريو الحرب
الاهليه ما يزال مستبعدا
فالجيش حث المدنيين على عدم الانخراط في
المعارك الجاريه
والسبب انها معركه على السلطه في المقام
الاول بحسب مراقبين
اما سيناريو عدم الحسم فانه وارد ايضا مع
تصعيد الدعم السريع هجومه ليلا بالمدفعيه
لكن ميزان القوه للجيش سيمكنه في النهايه
من الحسم ان لم يتطور الموقف الى حرب
شوارع في العاصمه
السيناريو الثالث
يرجح ان امد الحرب لن يطول كثيرا اي انها
معركه محدوده زمنيه
ويدعم هذا المؤشر الانشقاقات من جانب
المنتدبين في الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى
الانشقاقات القياديه اما السيناريو الرابع
فهو الرهان على الوسطات الخارجيه وهو
القاسم المشترك بين الطرفين لكنه هجوم
الدعم السريع ليلا يشي بانهم يحاولون
الحسم قبل بدء الوساطه في حين يؤكد الجيش
انه لن يرضى بالوساطه قبل ردع الدعم
السريع
اما السيناريو الاخير والذي يرجح ان تعود
قوات الدعم السريع الى دارفور مجددا اي
التحرك من هناك كقوه انفصاليه يصعب نزع
شوكتها
الله اكبر يعني احنا
بنتصارعوا في سلطه
الدوله
[موسيقى]
هذا وطلبت مفاوضيه حقوق الانسان في
السودان بحمايه المدنيين مع استمرار
للشبكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ودعت مفوضيه حقوق الانسان في بيان لها الى
الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار وفتح مسارات
امنه تساعد العالقين في الاماكن الخطيره
على الخروج الى اماكن امنه كما حثت
المفوضيه على حمايه المنشات الصحيه
وامدادها بالادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه
في غضون ذلك دانت نقابه اطباء السودان
الصراع على السلطه بين طرفي النزاع مع
خروج مستشفيات عده عن الخدمه تماما ابرزها
مستشفى الشعب التعليمي ومستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي وقالت النقابه ان قصف المرافق
الصحيه يعد انتهاكا واضحا للقانون الدولي
الانساني
والمواثيق ذات الصله
قبل ذلك تعرض مستشفى ابن سينا وهو احد
اكبر المستشفيات في العاصمه الخرطوم تعرض
لاضرار بالغه في بعض مبنيه بعد سقوط قذائف
عشوائيه عليه جراء للشبكات المستمره
والعنيفه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وبخلاف الاضرار التي تقع على
المستشفيات يجد الاطباء والمرضى صعوبات
كبيره في الوصول الى المستشفيات القريبه
من اماكن الاشتباكات
من امام المستشفى الدولي في البحر براس
العربيه سالم الهاشمي ينضم اليه الان سالم
اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه جديد المشهد
الميداني
واين تتركز الاشتباكات قبل ان اسالك عن
الوضع في هذا المستشفى الذي انت متواجد
فيه
نعم نحن الان في المستشفى الدولي
نبدا اولا بما يحدث الان في المستشفى
الدولي مستشفى الدولي استقبل 73 حاله
اصابه
يعني 73 من المدنيين وثمانيه اصابات من
العسكريين وصلوا الى المستشفى الدولي
والمسلسل الدولي الالي يعاني من العديد من
المشكلات الانسانيه منها نقص في الموادسيه
او الدعم
لتقديم الخدمه العلاجيه كذلك توجد نقص في
الكادر الطبي الفوائد الطبيه لا تستطيع
الوصول الى مستشفى ليقدم العلاج بشكل كامل
وربما يعني بالوضع الذي هو عليه الان
المستشفى ربما يغلق ابوابه حتى انه لا
يوجد لكادر طبيه لا وجود له ادوات او
معدات لوجستيه اضيف الى ذلك ان هناك مشكله
الجثانين الموجوده داخل المستشفى هي ثلاثه
ماني الان في العياده التي تقف خلفي هذا
العياده رقم اربعه هذه فيها جثمانين
لم يتعرف على
الجثامين التي داخل هذا داخل هذه العياده
لا يعرف فمن اصحاب هذه الجثابين ويسر
الجسر الرابط بين بحري
واندرمان وهو جسر شنبات هو الطريق الى
مشرحه ام درمان كان يمكن اذا كان موجودا
ان يكون هذا الجسر
طريقا تصل به هذه
الصوت يتقطع سالم ولكن الكهرباء والماء
والمعدات الطبيه متوافره في المستشفى وان
كان يعمل بظروف غير اعتياديه ظروف
استثنائيه يوجد ماء في المستشفى حتى الان
ولا قطره ماء واحده منذ انطلاق هذه
النزاعات وهذه او الانطلاق هذه الحرب منذ
ان نزع فتيل هذا هذه الحرب الى الان ولا
نقطه ماء واحده لا توجد في داخل هذا
المستشفى وهذه مشكله في حد ذاتها
الامدادات الطبيه باشكالها وانواعها هناك
يعني ندره حتى في توفر مجموعه من المعدات
اللجنه السودان المركزيه ونقابه الاطباء
كذلك ترسل النداءات تلو النداءات لاجل فتح
الممرات الاعلى طيب بالعوده
الى الذي سالتك جديد
الاشتبراني اخر ما وصلك من معلومات واين
تتركز الاشتباكات في هذه الاثناء
عمل اشتباكات مختلفه لكن ونحن هنا في داخل
هذا المستشفى نستمع الى دبي الرصاص كذلك
في هذه المنطقه في منطقه
شمبات والشعبيه نستمع الى ذويه الخاصه
وكذلك بعض المدافع الثقيله من مكان
تواجدنا هنا في المستشفى الدولي لكن ما
تزال الاشتباكات مستمره بكل تاكيد حينما
اخرج من المستشفى ساذهب الى نقطه اخرى
لنقل احداث هذه الاشتباكات عن
سالم عندما يعني
من الكادر الطبي في المستشفى وتس
اله ما هي ابرز الاحتياجات
هذا السؤال بالضبط سالته لاحد الكوادر هنا
في المستشفى وجدته من الاطباء الذين
يعملون في قسم الاحواضف قال لي بانه لا
يعرف من اين يبدا يعني لانها كلها
احتياجات مهمه الماء الكادر الطبي نفسه
توفر الادويه والعلاجات المعينات
اللوجستيه كالشاش والقطن وغيرها من
المعدات الادويه التي تستخدم في الحوادث
كل هذه الامور محتاج لها
بالتساوي يعني طيب
منذ قليل كنت مع الدكتور عطيه من لجنه
اطباء السودان تحدث عن وجود عشرات الجثث
في الشوارع التي تعذر نقلها الى المشافي
هل يمكن ان تؤكد هذه المعلومات سالم هل
فعلا هنالك عشرات الجثث في الشوارع نتيجه
القتال المستمر ولم يتمكن احد من انتشال
هذه الجثث او ارسالها الى البرادات او الى
المشارع في المستشفيات
ما هو مؤكد ان الاصابات كثيره جدا بالنظر
للكمه الهائله الذي يطلق من الاعيره
الناريه منذ انطلاق هذه الازمه لا اعرف
ناريه في كل الاتجاهات في كل الطرقات من
كل مكان في هذه العاصمه هذه الاعرابيه بكل
تاكيد اطلاقها في اماكن فيها سكان او حشد
سكاني كبير مؤكدا عدد الاصابات سيكون
الكثير هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى اذا
نظرنا الى المستشفيات بوضعها التي هي عليه
الان في استقبال المصابين او الضحايا او
حتى هذه الجثث نجد ان المستشفيات ما عادت
تحتمل الان لانها هي بالاصل ليست يعني في
الوضع الطبيعي كانت ستجد صعوبه في
استقبالهم فما بالك بالطرق المغلقه مبالغ
وان
المعدات
والامور اللوجستيه صعبه الوصول اليها تضيف
الى ذلك انقطاع للمياه تضيف الى ذلك عدم
وصول الكادر الطبي نفسه للمستشفى كل هذه
عوامل تجعل هذا الامر
وربما ان يكون صحيح الا يوجد
علينا الصليب احمر اطباء بلا حدود تعمل
على مساعده المستشفيات هل هذه المنظمات
متواجده هل تراها هل ترى بعض عناصرها
كوادرها في هذا المستشفى ام لا لا يمكن
لاحظ اي من هذه العناصر في المستشفى التي
انت متواجد بها وعمل المنظمات
المعضله في عمل المنظمات انها في الاصل
هذه المنظمات لا تجد الطريقه والسبيل وهذا
ما تقوله المنظمات حتى المنظمات المجتمع
المدني هنا في السودان تتحدث على انها لا
تجد الطريق للوصول لتقديم المساعده نفسه
اذا لم تقم الاطراف المتصارعه بفتح ممرات
امنه للوصول لوصول المساعدات وفتح مع مرات
امنه لوصول الكوادر الطبيه للمستشفيات
وحتى فتح ممرات امنه لنقل المصابين ليكون
هناك خط او طريق معين ينقل عبره المصابون
بالسيارات الاسعاف وتنقل به الجثابين
والجثث ليستلمها او تنقل الى المشارح هذا
هو الوضع الذي الحوجه الان لهذا الامر
الذي لم يجد اذان صاغيه حتى الان من
الطرفين المتنازعين من المستشفى الدولي في
بحر براس العربي سالم الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل هذه
المتابعه نستكمل هذه التغطيه من العربيه
للتطورات الاحداث الدراماتيكيه في السودان
الاخبار العاجله الان البعثه الاماميه
بالسودان
تتحدث وتقول ان الاليه الثلاثيه تحث الجيش
والدعم السريع على الالتزام
بالهدنه مراسله العربيه كان اشار منذ قليل
من قطاع المياه تماما في المستشفى الدولي
في الخرطوم
ايضا كثير من الاخبار العاجله مجلس نظرات
البجا يعني يقول ان شرق السودان لن يكون
موطئه قدم لاي قوه متمرده مجلس نظارات
البجاء يقول ان شرق السودان لن يكون موطئا
موطئ قدم لاي قوه متمرده بالطبع ربما في
اشاره الى قوات الدعم السريع ويضيف مجلس
نظارات البجا بالسودان ما يحدث هو تمرد
صريح ضد بلادنا وضد قواتنا
المسلحه اذا يعني موقف من مجلس نظارات
البجا هو الاول من نوعه بعد ثلاثه ايام من
القتال الدامي بين الطرفين اعود الى من
قطع من حديثي من القاهره مع الدكتور محمد
فايز فرحات مدير مركز الاهرام للدراسات
الدكتور محمد
اولا هل من تعليق على هذا الموقف لمجلس
نظارات البجه يعني بدات بعض الاطراف يعني
كنت كنت تقول انه في الاطراف خصوصا يعني
المكونات المدنيه تنتظر جلاء غبار المعركه
لتاخذ موقف هي تؤثر يعني كما يقال
دبلوماسيه الوقوف على التله والانتظار
الان لا عم اشوف انه مجلس نظرات البجع عم
ياخذ موقف ويقول ما يحدث تمرد صريح ضد
بلادنا وقواتنا المسلحه ما رايك بهذا
الموقف
يعني في راي هذا موقف يعني
متوقع واعتقد ان مثل هذه المواقف ستتضح
اكثر خلال الفتره المقبله مع اتضاح يعني
غلبه او قدره الجيش السوداني على حسم
المواجهه مع قوات الدعم السريع
مجرد ان يعني تتضح موازين القوى وقدره
الجيش على حسم هذه المعركه سوف تتزايد مثل
هذه التصريحات واعتقد ان هذا لن يقتصر فقط
على فاعلين محليين خارج الخرطوم او في
مناطق اخرى من السودان لكن اعتقد سيطال
قوات الدعم السريع نفسها يعني كنت اشير
قبل ذلك ان طبيعه هذه القوات يعني العلاقه
المصلحيه بالاساس هي التي يعني تربط يعني
عناصرها بهذا الكيان وبالتالي عندما
يدركون تغير موازين القوى
ان هذه القوات تواجه تحدي حقيقه تحدي بقاء
اعتقد انه سيحدث التغير سريع في الولاءات
وهذا سيسرع في رايي قدره الجيش السوداني
على حسم هذه
المواجهه فبالتالي في رايي ان ما عبر عنه
مجلس نظرات البجع هو
يعني موقف متوقع في ظل قدره الجيش على
يعني حسم المعركه في افق زمني محدد
المساله الاخرى يعني هي المكونات السياسيه
يعني حتى الان المكونات سياسيه لم يعني
تميل الى الوقوف على حاله الحياد وفي راي
هذا قد يتغير مع الوقت مع انتهاء او حسم
اشكال او معضله قوات الدعم السريع في رايي
ستكون هناك معادله امنيه جديده ستكون هناك
قوه واحده من الناحيه الامنيه
والعسكريه او حاله الازدواجيه هذه خلقت
نوع من الارتباك في المشهد السياسي
السوداني كان هناك محاوله من جانب قوات
الدعم السريع
ارتباطات او لبناء يعني ولاءات في الداخل
السوداني وحتى في الخارج السوداني
فبالتالي اختفاء قوات الدعم السريع اذا
افترضنا هذا السيناريو اختفائها من
المعادله الامنيه او العسكريه هذا سيكون
له ارتداد ارتدادات كبيره على المشهد
السياسي وعلى المشهد الامن ايضا في
السودان بشكل عام دكتور محمد لماذا لم
يصمد اتفاق وقفه اطلاق نار او الهدنه التي
طالبت بها الامم المتحده بالامس ابدا يعني
سريعا سقطت لماذا من مصلحه من يعني الا
يكون هنالك وقف اطلاق النار على الاقل
لسحب الجثث من الشوارع كما كان يقول لنا
الدكتور عطيه منذ قليل
يعني العوامل كثيره العامل الاول يتعلق
بطبيعه المعركه في راي هذه المعركه هي
معركه صفريه الجيش السوداني يعني يرى ان
هذه اللحظه لحظه مناسبه لانهاء مساله قوات
الدعم السريع وبالتالي اذا توقف الان يعني
بدون ان يكون هناك غطاء دولي واضح للجيش
السوداني اعتقد سيكون هذا خطر كبير من
وجهه نظر او حسابات الجيش السوداني حسب
رايي او حسب التحليل العامل الاخر ان
القوه الدوليه او المواقف الدوليه لا
تتحدث عن الخطوه التاليه يعني هي تتحدث
فقط عن وقف اطلاق نار لكن ما هي الخطوه
التاليه بعد وقف اطلاق النار لا توجد رؤيه
واضحه من جانب القوى الدوليه التي تتحدث
عن وقف اطلاق نار واقصد تحديدا القوه
الكبرى التي كانت معنيه بالملف السوداني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او الامم
المتحده او المبعوثين الدوليين لا يجب ان
ننسى ان هناك خبره بالتاكيد لدى الجيش
السوداني في يتعلق بمرحله ما قبل هذه
الازمه كانت هناك عمليه سياسيه وكانت هناك
القوه الدوليه ايضا عبرت عن مواقفها
واهتمامها بالملف السوداني وبالعمليه
السودانيه لكن ما الذي تحقق العمليه
السياسيه ظلت تواجه مشكلات كثيره جدا وهذه
المشكلات جزء منها راجع الى معادلات
السياسيه او المعادلات الامنيه الموجوده
داخل السودان طيب ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
القاهره الدكتور محمد فايز فرحات مدير
المركز الاهرام للدراسات شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه دكتور محمد
اعزائي المشاهدين يتعرض السودان الى ظروف
انسانيه توصف بالكارثيه نتيجه الحرب
المشتعله منذ السبت الماضي بين قوات الجيش
السوداني وعناصر قوات الدعم السريع نتابع
الاستهلاكيه اغلقت ابوابها تماما مع
مخاوفها من عمليات نهب محتمله وكعاده
الحروب لا تكتفي باتخاذ الموت رفيقا بل
تسعى لمزيد من الماسي فاحياء مختلفه
محرومه منذ السبت الماضي من المياه
والكهرباء الخاضعه للتقنين حتى قبل بدء
المعارك
وفيما احيى اتفاق الطرفين المتحاربين على
منح المدنيين هدنه انسانيه بعد ظهر الاحد
لتامين حاجاتهم لكنه سرعان ما تبخر بعد ان
عجزت ساعاته ثلاث عن تغيير الوضع مع
استمرار ضوي الانفجارات في الخرطوم
حنان المصري العربيه
[تصفيق]
هذا وشكلت الازمه الراهنه في السودان ضربه
جديده لاقتصاد البلاد كما ان استمرار
الصراع العسكري قد يجعل من الصعب خروج
السودان من الازمه الاقتصاديه الضاربه
بجذورها لعقود النظر
لا يمكن رسم صوره متفائله للاقتصاد
السوداني في ظل التصعيد المسلح بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل هذه
الاشتباكات كان الاقتصاد يرزح تحت سلسله
من الازمات التي يعود تاريخها الى حقبه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير واستمرت حتى بعد
سقوطه في 2019
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي تولت السلطه بعد
اسقاط البشير احيت امال السودانيين في
تحسن احوالهم اذ رفعت واشنطن بلادهم من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب وعادت
المساعدات الاجنبيه التي ناهزت ملياري
دولار سنويا الا ان الدول المانحه قررت
تعليق مساعداتها للسودان بعد الاجراءات
التي اتخذها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان في اكتوبر 2021
وشملت حل مجلس الوزراء والسياده
الانتقاليين مؤكده انها لن تستانف دعمها
للخرطوم ما لم تعد السلطه الى ايدي
المدنيين
الاقتصاد السوداني لم يشهد نموا منذ عام
2019 الا في عام 2021 فقد سجل نمو طفيفا
بنحو 0.5% لينكمش مجددا في عام 2022 صندوق
النقد توقع نمو اقتصاد السودان خلال العام
الجاري ب 2.5 الا ان الاحداث الاخيره قد
تعيد الاقتصاد الى مربع الانكماش ويحاصر
التضخم الاقتصاد منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فخلال 2022 ارتفع التضخم الى اكثر من
154% وفي يناير الماضي بلغت تضخم السنوي
نحو 83% لكن هذه الارقام كانت قبل الازمه
الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ويعتمد السودان على الخارج لتغطيه معظم
احتياجاته من النفط والغذاء وفي ظل تدهور
قيمه عملته وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا سجل
السودان خلال 2022 اعلى عجل في ميزانه
التجاري منذ 2012 ويساوي الدولار الواحد
حاليا في المتوسط نحو 600 جنيه سوداني
مقابل متوسط بين 18 الى 47 جنيها للدولار
الواحد في 2018 كل هذه العوامل انعكست
تدهورا في مستويات المعيشه واستراجع
القدره الشرائيه وارتفاع التضخم وارتفاع
مستويات الديون الخارجيه وغياب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبالطبع وفي حال
تفاقم الازمه الراهنه فان كافه المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه ستسير نحو الاسوا محمد زهير
العربيه
لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا ينضم اليه من
الخرطوم مصباح احمد وهو رئيس دائره
الاعلام في حزب الامه القومي والقيادي في
الحريه والتغيير استاذ مصباح اهلا وسهلا
بك الى هذه التغطيه من قناه العربيه ربما
سؤال وجداني انصح التعبير لماذا صوت
المدفع هو الصوت الوحيد المسموع الان اين
المكونات المدنيه اين الاحزاب اين قوى
الحريه والتغيير من كل ما يجري لماذا لا
تطرح وساطه مبادره لوقف القتال ما الذي
يجري
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم التحيه لك اخي
الكريم والتحيه لمشاهدي قناه العربيه
الحقيقه ان الصوت الاعلى هو للاسف الشديد
اليوم هو صوت البندقيه
والرفاق الحيه في كل انحاء العاصمه
الخرطوم والولايات للاسف الشديد وهذا يعني
يعود الى غياب الحكمه لاداره الخلاف ما
بين الجانبين العسكريين بالرغم من الجهود
الكبيره التي بذلتها القوه المدنيه
والسياسيه
والمجتمع الدولي في تقريب وجهات النظر بين
الطرفين الا ان الخيار المواجهه العسكريه
كان بالنسبه لهم هو الارجح وللاسف الشديد
نحن الان في هذه المسائل الحقيقيه التي
يشهدها الشعب السوداني وتشهدها كل انحاء
البلاد
وتزداد
الوضع الانساني تعقيدا كل ما ازدادت ساعات
المواجهه ما بين الطرفين اليوم الوضع
الحالي حقيقه الوضع يحتاج الى توقف الفوري
لهذه الحرب والجهود المبذوله ولا تزال
مستمره من اجل تابعه الاجواء لابد ان تصل
الى في هذا الموقف الاتصالات بين القوه
المدنيه وعلى راسها حزب الامه القومي مع
الجانبين مستمره
والمحاولات للاقناع الطرفين لضروره ايقاف
الحرب خاصه مع تزايد الازمه الانسانيه
وتزايد شحه المواد الغذائيه
والادويه الضروريه المستشفيات معظمها خرجت
من العمل كل ذلك
سيزيد من الضغوط على الجانبين من اجل
القبول بالتهدئه هذا ما نعمله ما نامل ان
يعني تتوصل اليه الاطراف خلال الساعات
المقبله حتى تتوقف هذه الحرب ولو وقت وقت
حتى تسمح
للشعب السوداني ان يتزوج بالمواد والمؤن
تكون هنالك ممرات للمرضى
الناس المحاصرين في مناطق الحرب وكذلك
ايضا الجثه متقدسه في مشاكل وفي المق في
الاماكن المغلقه طيب استاذ مصباح لا ادري
اذا كنت سمعت منذ قليل الدكتور محمد فايز
فرحات من من القاهره وعندما سالته عن موقف
القوى المدنيه يعني هو اعتبر ان جميع
القوى السياسيه المدنيه تؤثر الانتظار
يعني مواقفها رماديه الان لانها تنتظر
انقشاع غبار المعركه لتتخذ الموقف المناسب
يعني الدبلوماسيه الوقوف على التل
والانتظار لماذا
ليس صحيح عن القوى المدنيه موقفها منذ
البدايه موقف واضح جدا جدا انه الحل لهذه
الازمه
الاساس له هو العمليه السياسيه الجاريه
يجب ان يعود الاطراف تعود الاطراف كلها
الى طاوله الحوار
وان تناقش القضايا العالقه عبر منصه
الحوار حتى نمضي قدام لنقاط الخلافه
المختلف حولها في الجانبين العسكريين
ذلك حيات في هذه المعركه
يرفض
يرفض المواجهه الصفيه التي تجري الان بكل
اشكالها ونعتقد ان هذه الانا الطرفين
اندفعا في هذه الحرب
هل بقي هنالك اي امل بعوده الطرفين الى
طاوله الحوار ام لا يعني سبق السيف العزل
خلاص
الامل موجود الامل موجود هنالك اشارات من
الطرفين بانهما مستعدان لحد الان يعني
قرانا تصريح للسيد محمد حمد انه مستعد
للحوار البرهان اليوم في نقلت عنه احدى
الصحفيات انه مستعد للحوار لا ادري ان كان
هذا صحيحا ام لا ولكن اعتقد ان الطرفين
الان هم امام
مسؤوليه تاريخيه بعد ان وصلت الاوضاع الى
هذه النقطه التي لا اعود فيها وكذلك ايضا
الحاله العامه في البلد وخاصه في العاصمه
الخرطوم تزداد تعقيدا لانه هذا الوضع
سيتصور مواجهه ما بين جانبين العسكريين
الى انفلات امن شامل يشمل كل البلاد خاصه
اذا تحولت هذه الحرب الى حرف اهليه سيكون
الامر المدمر من الخرطوم مصباح احمد رئيس
دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه القومي
والقيادي في الحريه والتغيير شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه
اذا تتواصل للشبكات في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم ويقع مقر
القياده العامه في المنطقه الشماليه من
العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه كيلو مترات فقط
من مطار الخرطوم الدولي كما يتواجد بالقرب
من مقر قياده القوات البحريه ورئاسه اركان
القوات الجويه ويعد مقر القياده العامه
مركزا مهما وحساسا بالنسبه لقوات الجيش
السوداني ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص في محيط
المبدا مع تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه
ثقيله
وتيره الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع في تصاعد
خصوصا في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني
للمقر اهميه مركزيه لوقوعه وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني يتكون من خمسه ابنيه يضم قيادات
القوات البريه والبحريه والجويه
والاستخبارات العسكريه ما يعني ان المقر
معني بكافه الجوانب العسكريه والامنيه في
السودان
قبضنا
ماشيه حيه ماشيه حيه
زي ما قاعد تقولوا عرباتكم في فتيلنا ها
كويس الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
بيخلي سلاح وبيخلي عرباته ده معناته خلاص
انهزم انهزم وانتهى وينقهر ويندهر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
عربات الدعم السريع في قبضه القوات
المسلحه بالكامل اكثر من 15 كروزر رساله
لاي رساله لاي ميليشيا
هذا وظهرت مقاطع فيديو صورا تظهر معاناته
نحو 450 طالبا محتجزين بمدرسه كومبوني منذ
اندلاع الاشتباكات في الخرطوم الاطفال
المحتجزون يطالبون الحكومه السودانيه
بالوصول الى عائلاتهم وتوفير مواد غذائيه
ومياه في مجموعه من الطلاب الغين في مدرسه
الحاصل تقريبا كلهم 450 طالب بكام
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره بعد
قليل الزميله ريم بوجمره تصحبكم في ساعه
من التغطيه حول التطورات ادرماتيكيه
للاحداث في السودان اطيب التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات